there is not so much actually yeah  because the bishop just covers all this  yeah queen d2 king h3  queen f2 is nothing  yeah but what is next here 67 yeah  and  okay so you want to  okay i was lucky that he took it because  he blundered i think later on but uh  i expected him to play queen c5  and actually the game is still going on  it's not over  i would probably even come back to queen  f3 26 and then here i would think  ah so it would be a repetition and then  okay like one more repetition and then  some king g2 maybe or something  yeah it's a strange decision right to  exchange the queen's no actually i  understand he missed something he missed  he thought it's a fourth draw oh  because he missed he saw that c7 instead  of b6  uh c7 rook b3 c8 rugby five  so he wanted to have the  fortress probably it's a draw yeah i i  think so yeah  yeah  and and the event b6 yeah it was very  important to play b7 and then h5 and  then  c7  details